- Building a fully-equipped tree house
was the highlight of Harriet's summer,
even though it got in the
way of the class trip.
So we have this pronoun it
that they're underlining,
and we can either not change it
or we could swap it out
for she, they, or he.
So let's think about
what it is referring to.
So building a fully-equipped tree house
was the highlight of Harriet's summer.
So what it is referring to,
even though it got in the way, what is it?
Well, it is building a
fully-equipped tree house.
This right over here is a gerund phrase.
This right over here is a gerund.
It's a verb with an -ing
ending that's used as a noun.
Building a fully-equipped tree house.
This is the thing that got in the way.
And you could test it by
replacing the it with that.
Even though building a
fully-equipped tree house
got in the way of the class trip.
That's exactly what this
sentence is trying to say.
So it makes sense to me that if it is
referring to something that has no gender,
like building a fully-equipped tree house,
and it's not plural,
then you would just want to keep it, it.
You definitely wouldn't want it to be she.
Building a fully-equipped tree
house is not a female gender,
it's not a male gender,
and it's not a plural.
So you wouldn't want say they either.
So I'm definitely going with,
I'm definitely going with no change.